The Orinoco River is one of the longest rivers in the world.
It starts in the mountains of Venezuela and Brazil...
...and flows for nearly 1,300 miles to its delta on the Atlantic Ocean.
On its way south, the Orinoco flows through many different landscapes.
It moves past ancient stone formations, over waterfalls,...
...through rainforest areas, and across large plains.
The Orinoco Delta is the area where the river's water flows into the ocean.
The area around it is full of streams and small waterways.
These small rivers or tributaries connect to the Orinoco.
One of these tributaries called the Caroni,...
...features Angel Falls, the highest waterfall in the world.
The Orinoco Delta is also home to several South American Indian cultures...
...who have lived next to the river for thousands of years.
Actually, the name "Orinoco" comes from a local language.
It means "place to paddle".
One of these Orinoco Indian cultures is the Yanomami.
About 2,000 Yanomami people live near the river, far from the modern world.
For them and about 20 other local cultures, the Orinoco is an important natural resource.
The river not only gives them a means of travel, but a supply of clean water and food.
The rainforest around the Orinoco River also has many plants and animals.
There are more than a thousand different types of birds and many types of fish...
...including the dangerous piranha.
Around the river, you'll find the Orinoco crocodile.
These animals can grow to more than 18 feet long.
That makes it one of the longest crocodiles in the world.
There are big snakes on the Orinoco too, like the anaconda.
It's one of the largest kinds of snake anywhere in the world.
In the rainforest, you may also find a jaguar.
And on the open plains, you might be able to see the world's biggest rodent: the capybara.
However, over the past fifty years things have changed along the Orinoco.
Some of the cities and towns along the river have grown significantly.
The new industrial world is slowly coming to the delta.
Parts of the Orinoco now have dams to help control the water.
These dams also collect the river's water to create electrical power.
Companies have found valuable products like gold, diamonds, and even oil.
Now, very big ships travel up and down the river from the Atlantic Ocean to move these products.
There have been some big changes on the Orinoco.
However, many sections of the river and the areas around them have stayed almost the same.
There are now several national parks and rain forest preserves in the delta.
They will help this great river remain an important natural resource for Venezuela.
For now, the great Orinoco can continue to support the birds, animals,...
...and people that depend on it.